I felt you touch me I'm sorry mistress
you don't get to touch me
about a year ago I started having very
bad anxiety like truly honestly
debilitating in some ways my dating life
is a huge trigger in my anxiety it's
gotten to be like an issue like there
are people in my life that are worried
about me I feel like sometimes my dating
life is such a trigger because I feel
out of control in it you're always
waiting on someone to call you or
waiting on someone to text you or
waiting on someone to choose you and
like I just want to not I would just
rather not I've been thinking a lot
about ways to try to learn more about
how I can feel more possession of myself
and like feel more confident and more in
control and I feel like learning a
little bit from someone who has the
tools to control not only like their
actions and their behavior but the
actions and behavior of people around
them like that is kind of ideal I think
that it was really smart on your part to
look into how to think like a dominatrix
because how a dominatrix is in essence
is the opposite of someone who's anxious
like a dominatrix is always in control
she's very serene she's very tells it
like it is so much so that others
believe it say what size are you I'm
like a small medium yeah and I have a
6.5 foot and this is the most exciting
part of my day for sure well we're
pretty much the same size so this will
be easy
I'm thinking something like this for you
anything Wow that'll bring out your
power for sure it's suddenly gonna bring
out something
[Music]
hey Elena I feel like a different person
already honestly for placing the second
you put on leather you become slightly a
different person mm-hmm so I feel like
going through each archetype when I'm
being that the dominatrix that is the
most balanced and well-rounded that I
can be I'm channeling four main
archetypes come here slave Charles okay
what are you doing uncross your arms get
on your knees you should never be above
us you should always be below us so you
be on your knees in front of us at all
times do you understand slave yes
mistress
correct him and give him orders I
struggled a lot to be able to say the
things I needed to say it's just not the
way I'm used to interacting with people
what if I asked for him to crawl and get
me a water because I could actually use
a water right now state what you want
the idea of asking for what I want not
as a question but as like a statement
will be incredibly important like that's
not something I have done in the past
it's like the idea that I get anxious
because I'm waiting for something or
someone a dominatrix doesn't wait no I
want to water go get it for me
yes ma'am would you like him to call you
mistress yeah say that again please
yes mistress
mmm-hmm turn around
turn around slave you're gonna thank me
for this you just think I'm gonna
believe it
don't believe that I'm really powerful
this is the decision I can make
yes yes you should believe that I am
powerful that's right the seductress and
a dominatrix is more like a femme fatale
I'm going to play with you yes sir
should I want to because your body
belongs to me don't know that your
nipples are very very sensitive yes
mistress I'm gonna play with your
nipples to make you weaker and weaker
and weaker personal space is about three
feet when you get into someone's
personal space that immediately makes
them feel dominated I thought this one
was gonna be easier make him look at
your feminine form know that your
feminine form makes him weak lower your
eyes you can't even look at me right now
yes mistress
it feels very natural to like caress a
man's face and say like do you like what
you see but like then the next part of
being like but now I'm gonna step on you
with my heel how do you feel being under
my boots like that part didn't quite get
all the way for me
the mother archetype is nurturing
comforting makes the submissive feel
safe your ass belongs to me
I enjoy spanking you because it makes
you more submissive you feel safe in my
presence I know you do yeah tell them
what you want to do you can get over my
lap I'm going to spank you but you're
going to feel safe in my presence it's
definitely easier for me to naturally
say like nurturing statements like
you're safe I'm going to spank you but
you will feel safe in my presence it's
harder to say you're safe and you belong
here while like spanking a man who's
laying on top of you you can say you
know you feel safe with me I'm going to
take care of you you feel safe with me
I'm going to take care of you
I think I did it I've learned some
things today that honestly I couldn't
have learned in any other context in
ancient cultures we had goddess worship
males had actual goddesses to worship
but here we don't have that anymore in
our society so when men come into
dungeons to worship a dominatrix
he's worshipping the goddess I enjoy
this position slave yes this is the
position that I enjoy the most when you
worship me as your goddess would you
kiss the top of my shoe now remember
you're channeling goddess the goddess is
very poised tell me how grateful you are
when you did the goddess archetype that
would came very very naturally that's in
you Oh
Amy that's in you and I'm still getting
chills thinking about that example you
have permission to kiss my boot up to my
knee yes mistress I just got chills all
over my body because I had not said the
word permission in here all day and
that's the key word you just said it
because you're you totally channeling
goddess I love a goddess I love a
goddess energy I can sit in this around
all day I definitely felt the dominatrix
and you come out I really loved this
experience like it took me very far out
of my comfort zone you feel like a
different person I do think that there
are some like valuable lessons to be
learned about like how to hold oneself
how to ask for the things that you need
and that you want how to receive those
things because there are people in the
world that want to
you give them to you and that they will
get something out of it
something I would like to take away from
today is the idea that you can decide to
be in control and like that is something
that you can just turn on taking it out
in the real world is going to take some
time just know that it's already in you
[Music]